here we are
it's episode
anybody's guess for summer s'mores with
cone bone and the chill tones
um what it's just coming in over the
wire right now we just won worst opening
ever remember how this came to be this
came to be because on the podcast we
started talking about s'mores
and i said something that i've always
believed this is not a joke i think
they're terrible i just think that it's
a flawed concept and i do believe people
like s'mores
because they think they're supposed to
it's kind of enforced recreation
and forced joy but people don't really
like hey here's a graham cracker here's
a not very well melted marshmallow oh
and a piece of inferior chocolate let's
jam them all together
and chop it there's often nothing to
drink with s'mores people are i always
see kids
stuffing this roof tile glee down their
mouth no delicious they do it because
they've been instructed
by
the man that this is what they're
supposed to do but they don't really
like it i think that they are the most
delightful snack that you can have
especially no i don't expect you don't
think that excuse me sir i'm speaking
sir
i think that they are the most
delightful snack that you can have in
this environment excuse me ma'am i'm
listening yeah thanks point of order
okay i think that you can melt the the
marshmallow as much as you want to melt
it it gives you full control over your
s'more how many desserts can you say
that about and i just think that you're
i just
i don't think you've ever had the right
kind of s'more
before you're focusing on what is this i
don't know yeah what happened
sona is wrong
soonest oh so wrong
whole sona's wrong
hearing sona talk when she doesn't know
the score
makes me sad forevermore
[Music]
forevermore
forevermore
knows some more
listen sona i was
trying to undermine what you were saying
by playing that beautiful tune that then
turned into a total condemnation
of you that was an awful song best song
ever